my name is Jesse dollar Moore and I'm
sitting in for David packman while he is
out
Donald Trump's campaign kicked off in
Earnest it seems this weekend he was in
New Hampshire and South Carolina and a
lot of what you would expect from Donald
Trump took place in both events what it
shows me really is that it's going to be
even crazier this year than in 2016 or
in 2020 because his entire strategy has
changed surrounding campaign events so
it appears they're far more small and
intimate some would say that it's just
to mix things up but I think the any
Observer with any Acumen or
understanding of politics or Donald
Trump for that matter is really going to
understand it as a diminished support
from people in the party people are
tired of the games and the tricks and
the uh the over-the-top nonsense but
rather than change fundamentally how he
acts and what he does is it's a tertiary
change it's just a surface level
um
difference in how he's running things
because all of the craziness all of the
loopiness all of the lies all of the
insanity is still there in his New
Hampshire speech
he made this bold claim about how if he
were president or if he becomes
president he will end this Ukraine thing
in 24 hours
watch this
this guy's gonna be in World remember
crooked Hillary he's going to cause a
war in his first week in office because
they think that's my personality type
it's actually the opposite my
personality kept us out of War
and I told you before would have never
happened with Russia would have never
gone and Putin would have never ever
gone in
and even now I could solve that in 24
hours it's so horrible what happened in
those cities are demolished now the
people I'll bet you have millions it
could be millions of you how can you you
know they bomb a city to the ground
these big buildings come tumbling down
they say two people were injured not two
people
they lie I mean they lie but
if I were president you would have zero
chance that that war would have happened
that is telling and quite interesting
considering the fact that just about a
year ago
February 2022 Donald Trump was on the
the clay Travis and Buck Sexton show
they all went down to Mar-A-Lago to have
a good time on their podcast and he said
all kinds of glowing things about
Vladimir Putin he called him genius he
called him Savvy he called wonderful
it's insinuated he was a peacekeeper
remember this Mo keep in mind what you
just watched with him saying he would
solve this problem in Ukraine
remembering a look back to one year ago
with all of the things that he said
about Ukraine and Vladimir Putin uh I've
never seen anything like it I've I don't
think our country has ever been so low
you could take the five worst Presidents
in the history of our country and put
them together I don't think they've done
the damage that this Administration has
done Mr President in the last 24 hours
we know Russia has said that they are
recognizing two Breakaway regions of
Ukraine and now this White House is
stating that this is in Invasion that's
a strong word what went wrong here what
is the current occupant of the Oval
Office done that he could have done
differently
well what went wrong was a rigged
election and what went wrong as a
candidate that shouldn't be there and a
man that has no concept of what he's
doing I went in yesterday and there was
a television screen and I said this is
genius
Putin declares a big portion of the
Ukraine of Ukraine Putin declares it as
independent oh that's wonderful so Putin
is now saying it's independent a large
section of Ukraine I said how smart is
that and he's going to go in and be a
peacekeeper
that's the strongest peace for us we
could use that on our Southern border
that's the strongest peace Force I've
ever seen there were more army tanks
than I've ever seen they're going to
keep peace all right no but think of it
here's a guy who's very Savvy I know him
very well very very well by the way this
never would have happened with us had
I'd been in office not even thinkable
this would never have happened but
here's a guy that says you know I'm
going to declare
a big portion of Ukraine independent he
used the word independent and we're
going to go out and we're going to go in
and we're going to help keep peace you
got to say that's pretty Savvy and you
know what the response was from Biden
there was no response
he calls him a genius
it's wonderful what took place how smart
is that calls him a peacekeeper and the
strongest peace Force
does that sound like a man who's going
to run in as president of the United
States and solve the Ukraine problem in
24 hours this coming from the same guy
who was going to have infrastructure
week week after week after week after
week and it never got done until Joe
Biden took office
this coming from the guy who's going to
build the wall
that everything was just about to happen
never getting anything done other than
massive unpaid for tax cuts that
contributed to him adding 25 or taking
responsibility for
not taking responsibility for but being
responsible for 25 or so of our total
overall national debt inside of
four years the other part this little
clip I want to share is him talking
about how he invented the word Caravan
and he tells his rich friends who aren't
citizens who want to be citizens that
what they need to do is just cross the
border and then they'll just magically
be declared citizens I guess by the
federal government
watch this astounding misunderstanding
or just lies being told by Donald Trump
to give you a flavor for what's to come
in this campaign cycle
and I came up with the name Caravan
because we had Caravans of 15 20 000
people pouring in uh not when I I'll
tell you what we had it stopped pretty
early but now if you look at these
Caravans these are massive massive
Caravans and they have no idea who these
people are coming into our country
they're walking in unabated there's
nothing that nobody's asking them about
health or it's hard to get in I have so
many people can you help me become a
citizen I say yeah go to the southern
border just walk across the line you
know I have a guy rich guy wants to
become a citizen that he's gone through
everything he's gone to school to study
and this and this and that he's been
working for 11 years he hasn't been able
to pull it off okay
and I finally said to him you know
you've been working so hard why don't
you just
go down to Mexico
and sort of start walking across our
border
they'll take you gladly they won't even
talk to you now how ridiculous it is
like lots that Donald Trump does and
says it starts off as kind of a joke and
then his free association leads him to
tell a story that is almost certainly
untrue
uh but with a serious tone and tenor to
it
he's not telling telling it like it's a
joke he he he got serious there for a
moment he's telling people
that he believes the way to do it as
though we're just issuing citizenship to
anyone who crosses the southern border
the issue of immigration in this country
is is such a uh a murky topic because of
the lies that are told by the right
because of the lies and the the abject
just white nationalism that has infected
a massive swath of our country they talk
about it like it's an invasion they talk
about it like there's an impending War
that's going to take place it gets the
psychos in the Republican Party whipped
up into a frenzy
and all that does is exacerbate the
problem because they're not there to
solve it there's no evidence whatsoever
that Kevin McCarthy or anyone in
leadership in the Republican Party in
the House of Representatives wants to
solve the problem they want to continue
to be a political football they want it
to continue
to to
make hay for them be a be a campaign
slogan it's a prop to them they're not
there to solve problems and it's just
getting worse and worse and worse as
time goes on
email Services by big tech companies
scan every single email you send and
receive emails from your doctor your
spouse that's why you get those creepy
ads a few minutes later and other
companies collect your data every time
you open an email from them it's a huge
mess all of this information gets sold
around they can piece together where
you've been who you know what you like
and it's out there forever that's why I
recommend start mail start mail never
collects data from your emails it blocks
The Trackers embedded in the emails that
you receive start mail encrypts every
email you send protecting it from prying
eyes even the government start mail
never shows you ads and unlike other
services when you delete an email it's
gone forever and I love this part you
can create unlimited email aliases so
you don't have to give companies your
real email address which can really cut
down on spam you can seamlessly migrate
your emails and contacts from Gmail
Outlook Yahoo and others it's really
easy start taking your privacy seriously
by signing up for start mail you'll get
50 off your first year subscription go
to startmail.com Pacman the link is down
below